ça n'est pas vous monsieur doré qui
décidez de la démocratie way et ce sont
les 20 % des leurs qui ont décidé que
monsieur gautier devait être mère plutôt
que monsieur doré ses électeurs ont le
droit d'être entendu au même titre que
les vols et que ceux des quatre groupes
d'opposition ici présent jeu parce que
vous voulez monsieur doré avec la
démocratie
vous n'êtes pas un dictateur ici vous
êtes en charge de l'écharpé de maire que
monsieur métaux vous a confiée nous vous
proposons non mais je souhaite que les
bécasses qui ricanent non mais je
souhaite
il n'y a pas d'autres mots il n'y a pas
d'autres mots je souhaite que les
bécasses qui ricaine de voir les droits
de 20% des bolbécais être bafoués dans
men cim ce pouvoir rappeler à l'ordre
monsieur doré je vous rappelle alors il
n'est point de normal vous il n'est pas
normal non seulement après que vous
considériez à 20% des vols mais vous
n'avez vous apparaissez 11 négligente
monsieur et que c'est joli moment de sa
cellule des briquets au mètre 90 des
droits dans l'opérationnel au baalbeck
et qu'il représentait c'est une honte
c'est une honte de votre parentaux qui
lui de traiter les élus de la majorité
de bécasses ce sont des bêtas cent des
femmes qui rigolent quand les élus de
l'opposition défendre les droits de
leurs électeurs et qui ne vont pas
prendre la parole une seule fois pendant
six ans pas plus qu'elles ne l'ont prise
pendant les six dernières années
ça n'est rien d'autre que des bécasses
et mme adam bomb et qui ne s'est fait
remarquer en en six ans quand me blanche
quand me blanc comme un animal de ferme
quand j'intervenais n'a pas son mot à
dire
c'est une honte monsieur doré stone et
votre équipe si vous voulez vous montrer
digne de l'e charbon qui nous a été
confiée à monsieur potier déjà je vous
donne la preuve sera déjà vos propos
sont fortement déplacer c'est pas digne
c'est pas dit c'est vous ce que vous
faites qui n'est pas digne non non non
c'est à ne pas livrer gandelu et des
anneaux messieurs laurent lesquels nous
devons siégé de droit venons vous êtes
en train de faire vous êtes en train de
défier vous êtes en train traité jean de
dopés caleçon des images de fermes
je ne laisserai dont l'ascension
monsieur eu un comportement que celui ci
fait honte à notre vision nos électeurs
ont le droit
ce nos électeurs ont le don
avec peut représenter ce petit coup de
papattes micro sous le nom tous ces jeux
il ya deux positions qui semblent
incompatibles moi j'ai bien noté bon moi
ce que je souhaiterais maintenant c'est
que l'on puisse s'entendre même si on
n'est pas d'accord et que ça redescende
d'un ton j'interviens pour essayer de
calmer tout le monde et que l'on puisse
continuer le conseil de façon un peu
plus un peu plus calmes parce qu'on
n'est pas